فيما تتجه الانظار الى ميامي حيث سيمثل
الرئيس السابق ظل ترامب امام محكمه فيها
يعمل الاخير على اظهار المواجهه مع خصومه
وكانها مع الشيوعيين واليسريين
والماركسيين على حد وصفه وصف ترامب جاء في
اعلان له على تروس سوشيال حيث اوضح انه
يتحضر للتوجه الى دورال في ميامي مؤكدا
على ضروره البقاء مع انصاره اقوياء وهزيمه
هؤلاء الخصومه الذين اتهمهم بتدمير
الولايات المتحده بشكل ممنهج
يريد ان يظهر وكانه يواجه اعداء امريكا
المحاكمه تاتي من هؤلاء الشيوعيين او
الماركسيين لذا فهو يحاول تصوير المدعين
ليس كاعداء الله فحسب بل اعداء للولايات
المتحده يعتقد انه امريكا واحد
ومع تصاعد الجدل بين انصار ترامب وخصومه
بعد توجيه لائحه اتهام من 37 تهمه للرئيس
السابق تتزايد مخاوف حدوث اعمال عنف سياسي
خاصه بعد تغريده النائب الجمهوري المؤيد
له التي قال فيها ان البلاد وصلت الى
مرحله الحرب
انه بالتاكيد شيء مقلق عندما يتصاعد خطاب
هؤلاء السياسيين اكثر فاكثر كما تسمع ايضا
مالكي الاسلحه وموقفهم ولا يساعد هذا في
خفض التصعيد والجمهوريين بحاجه الى اعتبار
ان كلماتهم قد تكون خطيره اذا راينا عنفا
سياسيا في الايام المقبله
في غضون ذلك يصر ترامب رغم توجيه لائحه
الاتهامات الفيدراليه له على اكمال حملته
للحصول على ترشيح الحزب الجمهوري ومنددا
بما يصفه بحمله الاضطهاد ضده وتسييس وزاره
العدل للقضاء حسين الطوض العربيه واشنطن
لمتابعه المزيد
من الاخمج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات